aoka les élections municipales du 7
novembre porte beaucoup sur l'enjeu de
la sécurité
le maire sortant n'en démord pas le
territoire voisin qu'elle s'attaquait
est selon lui contrôlé par le crime
organisé on voit là depuis plusieurs
mois circule et des gens sur le
territoire ici ne passent à travers
aucun des membres et ce qui les attire
ici on se sait quoi c'est les cabanes
qui forment ce cannabis son opposant du
parti unité citoyenne julie tremblay
cloutier est aussi notamment campagne
sur la question de la sécurité même si
elle admet n'avoir aucun contrôle sur ce
qui se passe à cannes et s'attaquer
c'est clair qu' on voit bien des gens
car et d'autres tours de milieux qui
viennent consommé ici est que souvent
mais ces milieux là aussi son propre et
ça à toutes sortes d'autres activités
illicites
le 13 juin 2021 une grosse fête a eu
lieu dans le stationnement de la
boutique de cannabis le green room où
les mesures sanitaires n'étaient pas
respectées
deux semaines plus tard le chef de gang
harcèlement au point était assassiné
alors qu'il était attablé sur une
terrasse du commerce
non
depuis l'incident la terrasse du green
room est fermée de manière permanente et
aucune fête vous êtes autorisé
grand chef de kanesatake et au moins
deux derniers il rejette les allégations
pascal quévillon selon lesquelles sa
communauté serait contrôlé par le crime
organisé
depuis 2004 aucune force policière
autochtone n'est présente à cannes et
s'attaquer depuis la sûreté du québec et
responsable de la sécurité sur le
territoire mohawk
une porte parole de la saq nous indique
collaborer avec tous les citoyens et
organismes de cannes et s'attaquer
comme c'est le cas ailleurs au québec
les policiers vont parfois rencontrer
des individus qui sont réfractaires à
leur présence sur le territoire
propriétaire de la boutique de cannabis
les diables verts prévenez moi qui étais
né coulisses a combattu la sûreté du
québec durant la crise d'oka en 1990
vous êtes d'accord prune sécurité de la
route maintenant la communauté malienne
aucun doute mais la sécurité est sculpté
de québec
pour les autres on
les autres selon pascal quévillon c'est
aux gouvernements provincial et fédéral
d'intervenir non deux paliers de
gouvernement ferme les yeux petit
j'entendais parler au fédéral dans leurs
campagnes électorales et l'eau potable
et comme note autochtone était sensible
à ce qui se passait mais comme note
autochtone mais oui l'eau potable est
important
mais que le crime organisé est pris le
contrôle d'un territoire autochtone au
départ la communauté c'est très
insécurisant pour la communauté julie
troncs des cloutiers avance vouloir
collaborer avec les autorités - voisine
le territoire est un territoire non
surveillée ou y aucune force coercitive
qui s'implique donc c'est clair qu'un
crime organisé le perçoit comme une
facilité par un endroit où ils peuvent
flâner donc là pour moi c'est clair
qu'une partie de la solution passe par
des forces de sécurité mais c'est au
conseil de bande et aux citoyens canet
s'attaquer de trouver les meilleures
solutions pour rues pour prêter n'arrive
wac et une église la solution la
sécurité doit passer par le dialogue
trente ans d'insultés dans ce tumulte et
30 ans d'indifférence par les forces
extérieures on doit parler ensemble en
nous aux cuisines avant on doit
sceller
une réconciliation qui serait bienvenu
pour améliorer sentiment de sécurité
chez les allochtone comme chez les
autochtones